the emotion yesterday after the the
screening was very touching images to to
watch a
what was the feeling just very just very
simply what was the feeling after the
screening yesterday and this uh standing
ovation
um
for a couple of seconds it sort of
scared me because
it felt like we were stuck in a loop
you know when we were standing and um
the Applause and the reaction from the
audience just
the uh the the energy of their
reaction was uh
yeah it just seemed to go it just seemed
to go on and on and I I was uh
I was yeah you know you you become like
a kind of a
because we're all sort of mommies and
daddies of the film and in a weird way
my win of course this is her
baby but um
proud I was very proud
to to
see the comeuppance of
the result of good work
I haven't seen the thing but I know it's
good because they said so
I trust them well you surprised to be
chosened for the visual and how was it
to to shoot in in French was it
difficult for you
um was I surprised uh yeah I thought
someone had made a there was a terrible
misspelling somewhere
and my will and I ended up in
the wrong room at the same time
um
my I mean I I didn't really I didn't I
didn't feel any hesitation with regard
to the
to the guy to the character and all that
the
oh
or the language
necessarily I didn't find particularly
intimidating
you know a bit of a you know it's a
it's like running through the raindrops
um
but uh
my question my question to my win when
we first met was I
maybe you want to try a friendship guy
um as king you know do we
you know as Louis cans
um
she thought about it for a second she
said I thought about that too
now I want you to do it so
um
I thought it was very brave of her uh to
choose
some hillbilly from Kentucky to play
Louis guns
um very brave
um
so yeah I was I was instantly I mean up
for it wanted to do it just wanted to
make sure that that it wasn't uh
I don't know stepping out of my boxing
into someone else's you know getting
into other people's
things
cultural thoughts weirdness
um but I'm glad she persisted that I'm
glad I persisted and uh
the experience
of doing the film in French was
I wanted at least to be
my pigeon French at least I wanted it to
be in some
regard I wanted to be able to improvise
if necessary
so
that was that was uh
again you know you're way outside your
language
your vernacular and and you're
a way of expressing yourself
so yeah it was
um
she was very patient with me I'll put it
that way you had mentioned in an
interview in the Sunday Times back in
2021 that you felt boycotted by
Hollywood do you still feel that do you
still do you feel that the tide is
changing towards you doing major Studio
films again
um it's not my tide
we're discussing
um did I feel boycotted by
um Hollywood
well I mean that you'd have to not have
a pulse to feel at that point
to to feel like
no none of this is happening it's this
is actually just a kind of a weird joke
you've been asleep for 35 years
um so just let the weirdness commence
of course you know I mean when you're
asked to resign from a film you're doing
because of
something that is
merely a bunch of kind of vowels and
consonants floating in the air
um
yeah you feel a bit boycotted do I feel
boycotted now no
not at all
um
but
I don't feel boycotted by Hollywood
because I don't think about it I don't
think about Hollywood I don't
I don't have much further need for
Hollywood myself I don't know how you
guys feel but yeah I think
it's a very strange funny time where
everybody
would love to be able to be themselves
but they can't
because they must fall in line
with the person in front of them
you want to live that kind of life I
wish you the best I'll be on the other
side somewhere you know a journey we
know that can is a wonderful place for
movies but it's also a great mediatic
circus so how do you feel coming here
coming back on the spotlight a lot of
controversy not especially talking about
the movie how both do you feel with that
sometimes toxic surrounding thank you
I mean um
first came to can
use like 92 or something
I came to can accidentally to the
festival accidentally with him and
um
it was a absolutely a circus like I had
nothing I'd ever seen
it remains
the same and I think that's very good
um
different phases
same actions same everything
um
and so the circus the circus part is the
weirdest part
um
because
it's it's sort of like
like you say you know
people folks out there want to
well I mean
you believe what you believe
the truth is the truth you know
um
as far as
it being a positive or A negative
to the film all this sort of
um
abstract Whispers
you know but that all that does is it
maybe maybe people talk about the film
in this way or they will talk about your
work in in a certain way
up to a certain point but the fact is
but we're all here because we made a
film
not because we have a product to sell
but we made a film
everything that
the majority of you who've been reading
for the last five or six years
have been reading
uh I mean with regard to me and my life
the majority of what you've read is
fantastically
horrifically written fiction
um
so
the fact is as I was saying we're here
to talk about a film but
you know it's like asking a question how
are you doing but what's underneath
in the subtext is God I hate you
do you know what I mean
so that's the sort of media thing but
the focus should be simply on the fact
that
it's a miracle to get a film made
that you care about in the first place
so you succeed there you win right there
um but to get a film like this made
and with the caliber of people
and the vision
of
absolutely you know
the forward moving
uh
artist
um
that that's the focus that should be the
real Focus Mr dab relating to what you
said earlier uh there has been a bit of
controversy about your presence here in
can regarding your past legal matters
personal legal matters
um what would you say to those who think
you should not have been here at the
festival
[Music]
so we're talking theoretically about
what would I do if there were people who
didn't want me to come to the council
Festival
what if one day
they did not allow me under no
circumstances no matter what
I cannot go to McDonald's
for life
that's right
because somewhere
if you got them all in one room
there would be 39 angry people watching
me eat a Big Mac on a loop
just for fun
um
who are they why do they care
some kind of
some species some Tower of
mashed potatoes
covering the light of a computer screen
anonymous
with
apparently a lot of spare time
I don't think I'm the one who should be
worried
I think I think people should really
think about
what it's all about really